so tell me what was it about Mr
harrigan's phone that made you want to
write and direct it I thought that there
were a lot of different themes I thought
of it when I read it kind of a little
like the body by Stephen King that was
turned into the movie Stand By Me and
that there's a a coming-of-age story but
it's kind of paranormal and there's an
uneasiness and a creepiness it's kind of
just under the surface a little bit and
I appreciated that I also appreciated
the you know one of the themes about you
know technology and the good and the bad
um and then you know how we're all
affected by it so those things
especially during covid when everybody
was locked down and this opportunity
came to me I thought this would be fun
to explore do you consider this a horror
film out and out no
no that was one of the things there yeah
I thought right off the bat it's not a
horror film it's kind of like a
brother's Grim cautionary fairy tale if
you will
um and so I appreciated the relationship
between Mr Harrigan and Craig
as the center of the story and how you
know how they have more in common than
they than they they might think and then
how technology affects that relationship
um and what it does to them both at the
beginning it initially good and then is
it bad is it good I don't know but I
just like the questions raised but no I
don't think of it as a horror nobody
nothing jumps out of the closet needs
you it is though
um dealing with paranormal and you know
kind of ghosts and stuff like that
um so what was it that kind of made you
want to jump into this kind of uh
Supernatural Arena you know I I didn't
really it's funny you say that because I
can understand and I understand your
question and I I agree I would probably
ask that same question to me it wasn't
trying to dip my toe into the
supernatural as much as I was just drawn
to the characters and how lost
affects you whether you're in your 80s
or whether you're a young boy and the
fact that they have we come to find out
a certain shared loss that they're both
there there's a sadness about both these
little boys one happens to be in his 80s
and a billionaire but I enjoyed kind of
opening that up really leaning into that
and having them be best best friends and
have more in common than you would think
and so that was a central relationship
that really drew me to it the other was
was was the gravy on top can you talk
about the differences between working
with an elder Statesman like Donald
Sutherland and a young man like Jayden
Martell first they're both unbelievable
actors and I don't say oh Jaden's an
unbelievable young actor I say he's an
unbelievable actor and I would quote
Donald on that I mean after two days
I've been working together Donald called
me over he called me governor and he
said Governor come here for a second
I'd come over and he whispered my ear he
goes Jayden is a fine fine actor he said
he is challenging me in all the best
ways and I said good we you know we we
cast well but it's fun it was fun to
watch their interview interplay because
they really were just two fine actors
with a very special bond both on and off
screen did Donald Sutherland have any
trouble with the with the technological
aspect of the phones or anything because
no he's he was he has his own iPhone or
whatever and he does it all and
everything but he was amazed when we
props brought out all the old phones the
different brands and things and he got
that first iPhone and he goes it's so
little
he said my fingers won't fit
um so but we were all kind of amazed at
that you know Jaden included uh I was
gonna say and and Jaden similarly I
imagine he was probably barely born when
the first iPhones came out yeah and um
yeah so and he looked at it the same way
he goes wow he doesn't have anything on
it you know he doesn't have any of the
stuff I wear used now on it but um but
it was good that he was really Adept at
it and Donald at being a fine actor did
a good job of pretending he had never
ever held a phone like that before so
that's fun to watch his his growth in
learning about the phone I think is one
of the the the fun the fun aspects of
the film I know that you see this more
as a as a character piece but did you
enjoy the supernatural aspects of it was
this something you would like to explore
further
yeah I would definitely I enjoyed um
working you know with our department
heads and also with John Schwartzman or
DP and talking about lenses and talking
about where we want to put the camera so
a lot of times very low angle on the
floor and the idea being that we're
going to present this as we're going to
make you a little uneasy or attempt to
make you a little uneasy this is not a
normal it's not normal coverage of a
scene and it's kind of slowly creeping
along all the time just in Aid of that
uneasiness and getting under your skin
it's still normal but there's why am I
thinking there's something off about
this so that was really really fun that
was really fun okay okay and what do you
have coming up next I don't know I mean
I'm writing some stuff right now so
we'll we'll see you know something
something else different and fun I hope
okay great well thank you so much I
really appreciate it thanks Elise I
appreciate it